it's great to be joined today by David
new earth who's a freelance journalist
blogger author of a number of books most
recently alt America the rise of the
radical right in the age of Trump David
thanks for joining me this topic is so
important we've been talking about
political violence we've been talking
about the rise of the alt-right maybe to
start with we could talk a little bit
about the sort of genesis of the this
modern all right
radical pro-trump element of the
american right what's the sort of
genesis of it what groups may be
coalesced in order to create the group
that exists today or what what do you
see is the origins of it well it is as I
explained in the book I trace your
origins back to the 1990s and the rise
of the patriot militia movement because
that was probably really first started
seeing this culture built around
conspiracy theories and basically you
know alternative facts and that was
where I first really observed this
epistemological bubble that they create
for themselves it's kind of an
alternative universe built out of these
conspiracy theories and alternate
effects that actually functions as a
place where these folks
epistemologically dwell and it's it's
it's really difficult to get people out
of this bubble once they are in it and
it has a really powerfully unhinging
effect can you talk about what the
common
I hate to call them issues or policy
positions that this radical pro-trump
right has because that almost gives them
sort of too much credibility but can you
at least talk about some of the the
ideological themes that seem to unite
the individuals that are part of that
that movement well I think the the
overarching theme and it's one that's
been around like I say since the
nineties is that there is a massive
conspiracy of globalist
or communists or what what have you to
enslave mankind and destroy Western
civilization and this is actually part
of I think Donald Trump's worldview - he
clearly believes that there is a culture
war going on between white people and
non-whites and liberals and he sees
himself as a culture warrior on behalf
of his white working-class base and and
that's why he behaves the way does does
Donald Trump actually appeal to the
majority or a significant portion of
this new modern radical alt-right or has
he just kind of become a convenient
vessel through which they maybe see an
opportunity to inch closer to the
America they'd like to see well I think
it's both it's kind of a symbiotic
relationship he definitely does things
that signal to them that he's on their
side including such things as you know
pardoning the the folks behind the Bundy
stand up and doing all these various
sorts of moves that actually help very
clearly are sort of signals to this
radical base that he's on their side and
they uniformly interpret those signals
as see Donald Trump's really on our side
and of course after things like
charlottesville when when Trump said you
know some of these folks out here are
very fine people there was quite a bit
of uproar about that and you recall that
he at one point said well no I denounce
all white supremacists and then the next
day said some of them are very fine
people they they they uniformly ignore
the disavowal because what happens is
they say well oh he's just doing this to
you know sort of maintain his political
viability he's just being practical we
know what he's gonna do
but we understand you know he's really
he really is on our side and the main
thing that they see him doing is
creating a lot of chaos and basically
destroying the existing system which is
really what they want him to do
they finally spoken to David when I
interviewed Richard Spencer the the
well-known all right white nationalist I
sort of talked to him about this reality
that on the one hand Donald Trump has
appealed to people like him but at the
same time he does have a daughter who
converted to Judaism and one of the most
powerful people Jared Kushner his
son-in-law also is Jewish and pointed
out some of these other data points and
what Spencer basically said and I'm
paraphrasing here is listen this is as
publicly as you're going to get a
president signalling that he's on our
side so we just are gonna ignore that
stuff yes he's got a you know converted
to Jewish daughter and he claims he
disavows white supremacy and he says he
didn't know who David Duke was and then
when he found out he said he disavowed
him or whatever but we understand that
this is as much as a president really
can do and we recognize that yeah and
yet even yesterday Donald Trump declared
that I am a nationalist yeah you don't
get many more powerful signals to this
base than that because of course they
see themselves as white nationalist and
and they but they're perfectly happy
having him declare as a nationalist
because that's really what they're about
anyway in retrospect did the entire
questioning of President Obama's
birthplace and birth certificate did
that now we can tell serve is a pretty
good precursor to the movement that has
been built around Donald Trump yeah I
mean it seems kind of silly because at
the time I think most of us dismissed
this is this is just cookery and nobody
really believes it yet if you pull I
think Republicans now something like
seventy percent of them believe it to
this day that Barack Obama was not
legitimately
in the United States and it was yeah it
was it's a very good proxy for people's
gullibility and willingness to absorb
the these fake facts and alternative
theory or these conspiracy theories and
it's obviously you know that something
that Donald Trump picked up on very
early it was basically the foundation of
his political career was his you know
pushing the birth or conspiracy theory
back in 2011 do you think that so we've
talked a lot here on the program about
how by any objective measure the
overwhelming majority of political
violence in the United States is being
done by the right 74% of murders for
political reasons are done by right-wing
extremists that's not even counting
extremist Islamic ideology which I
consider to be also far-right just the
flavor of that but even without counting
that we're talking about 74 percent the
right likes to frame you know an T for
people through a bike lock at somebody
or broke a piece of glass but your
statistics don't bear out that that it's
the left can you talk a little bit about
whether there is more of a tendency to
violence now than before Trump whether
we're seeing an actual embolden
that can be seen in statistics in any
way or is it just getting more coverage
now no I think it's actually happening
more you know in the first month after
Trump's election we had over a thousand
hate incidents in this country which is
an unbelievable escalation of the the
rate of eight incidents SPLC maintained
a database on this and I went through
that that database and figured out that
nearly about forty eight percent of all
of those incidents those thousand or so
incidents that happened in that first
month 48% of them featured people either
using Trump's name like chanting Trump
Trump Trump to intimidate and threaten
minorities or using his rhetoric such as
you know make America great again or
or what-have-you or build the wall or in
some cases just saying Trump is going to
get rid of you people nearly nearly half
of those incidents feature that kind of
rhetoric which tells you a lot and I
think the main thing it tells you is
that Donald Trump's election essentially
gave permission for people who have been
holding back on their innate racism for
many many years to express it as openly
as they can and you know we're seeing
all these viral videos that are coming
out of white people being ugly racist to
somebody you know obviously that kind of
stuff happened before and obviously the
fact that we're seeing these now has a
lot to do with the fact that everybody
has a cellphone but it also has a great
deal to do with the fact that since the
election racists and haters have
definitely definitely believed that that
trumps election more or less gave them
permission to be as ugly as they want to
be yeah what do you you mentioned viral
videos what's your understanding of this
alt rights use of memes and and internet
humor I mean it does seem to be
effective as sort of inserting ideas
into culture including without everybody
necessarily understanding the source or
background because you can put a funny
meme out there that is just funny and it
sort of gets it obtains cachet and
people don't necessarily know the
xenophobic or racist origins of it yeah
well that's what they really believe is
that they're mean magic is spreading
their message and you know to some
extent it's true hey this is not your
grandfather's Klan hey're they are not
the backward-looking
hate group so we've been dealing with
for many years the alt-right is very
much a forward-looking very savvy in
terms of culture pop culture very savvy
in terms of leveraging social media to
get what they want and this is one of
the the frightening things about them is
that they basically are able to reach
this whole new
audience that they were never able to
reach before when they were just you
know organizing cross burnings down in
the south they're able to basically
recruit a whole generation of mostly
young white males between the ages of 15
and 30 that's that's their demographic
and that's who they aim for David in the
brief time we have left what happens to
the alt-right after trump the Tea Party
which did very well in the 2010 midterms
eventually as many people predicted just
kind of half petered out and half became
integrated into the mainstream
Republican Party slightly modifying the
sort of average view of Republicans what
do you see is the future of the
alt-right movement beyond trump well I
say that I've been saying quite
regularly in fact even before I wrote
this book that if Trump disappears
tomorrow we're gonna have this problem
for another ten years because the Trump
represents this very very big shift in
culture in American political culture
and that isn't going to go away
overnight and a lot of that this has to
do with the way that the Republican
Party has admitted this these levels of
extremism to right within its ranks and
obviously Donald Trump's this sort of
apotheosis of that so even if even if
Trump disappears tomorrow there's gonna
be trumpets all throughout the
Republican Party and they're not going
to be able to get to them very easily in
fact I think that you know the
Republican Party is basically now doomed
to be the party of Trump I don't know
how well they'll do electorally
I actually believe that that the vast
majority of Americans are still not
hateful like this
I think Trump's election was a fluke and
and hopefully you know we'll get this
boat ship turned around but it's gonna
be a long slow haul and anybody that
thinks that just impeaching Trump is
gonna solve the problem
is deluding themselves this is going to
be with us for a very long time yes the
the impeachment has not a solution to
the broader problem is something I've
been talking about as well the book is
called alt America the rise of the
radical right in the age of Trump highly
recommend that we've been speaking with
the book's author David Muir David thank
you so much for talking to us hey thanks
for having me on Dave